oblivion some say the best game of all
time
[Music]
then pay with your blood a game with
such immersive universe you really feel
like you want to be part of it
mee mee mee mee mee mee mee mee mee mee
mee mee mee mee mee mee mee mee and
don't even get me started on the combat
system
[Music]
stop you violated the law hey the core
define or serve your sentence so lately
I've been obsessing over oblivion videos
so I thought I'll make a video on it
that's that's it that's pretty much it I
play this game a long time ago
and it's such an impressive game because
see it's really before its time now
looking back at it it really hasn't aged
well and it's so funny to watch these
mistakes that it had because the project
was so ambitious that parts of it is
just bound to [ __ ] up and mess I think
parts of it is just bound to be messed
up and we're just gonna look at all the
bad stuff today but don't take my word
for it
take my man Todd [ __ ]
Howard this beautiful man the creator of
the series if you have not bought skyrim
yet on every single console out there
he's going to be extremely upset with
you I'm gonna play quarterback for the
Cowboys and I'll be like I'm gonna make
video games and everyone's gonna play
you dork go back to the Chess Club who's
laughing now yes I was in the Chess Club
[Laughter]
yes I was in the Chess Club
whatever I'm cool now trust me i made
oblivion it's really it's a good game i
think the big thing is the AI we have in
the game design the system radiant AI
that allows the people in the world
to react really intelligently and they
sort of have their own goals so they can
look at their environment around them
and decide how they want to accomplish
them so the game has extremely
intelligent AI what have we here another
plaything you dance for me little one
yes you will I will make your corpse
dance and then tear itself apart and not
just intelligent ai ai Dex truly thinks
for itself mee mee mee mee mee mee mee
mee mee mee mee mee mee mee mee mee mee
mee mee it was at this moment Jackson
knew such extreme intelligent AI that
they implemented amnesia in the game you
see here the guard kills the beggar oh
my goodness excuse me are you all right
by the Divine's this person is dead
literally me whenever I kill a person
and don't even get me started on the
flawless voice acting in this game it's
truly we heard that thieves broke into
the arcane university the Imperial
Legion compound and the temple all on
the same night wait a minute let me do
that again
I heard the thieves broke into the
arcane university the Imperial Legion
compound and the temple all on the same
night take care good talk good talk I
truly feel immersed Wow I love this one
because it really shows the different
range the voice actors can do of course
it's all just made up to give them an
excuse to keep us down thank you kind
sir
you give him a coin and have you heard
about that ghost of the old man that
looks out into Nibin Bay each night
after he gave him a coin that his balls
drop as soon as he gets money thank you
kind sir have you heard about that ghost
of the old man that looks ardent he says
Christ apparently to save space on the
game they had some voice actors do the
same line if there's a line that was
going to be repeated a lot they have one
voice actor do it instead of every voice
actor do it and in putting it together
as a montage it's goddamn beautiful
here's a here's when you give them coins
I'm only asking for enough to
thank you time sir Thank You cancer
blessing she's a shadow upon thank you
kind sir
blessings of akatosh upon thank you kind
sir
blessings of the shadow upon ye forget
thank you kind sir
blessings of stand are upon thank you
came dad and don't even get me started
on how incredible the dungeon-crawling
the quests were in this game you what
are you doing here as the council gone
mad
there's no time I'm the only one left
it's the only one that's why me
thank god you're the only one that
survived at least one lived truly
intelligent AI maybe he's fine
you know what maybe he's okay now he's
definitely dead the game was so
groundbreaking that you could poison
people's food feed them to him as a
sleek way to assassinate less watch
welcome have you ever heard I'll go tell
her tales she's the best bard I've ever
met of course being a bard is almost as
bad as being it's you
when the edibles kick in yeah so they
all ate the poison apple hello there
[Laughter]
hello oh my god have you heard of the
higher
ah Jesus Christ
now some may say the the dialog in
Oblivion is too low awkward I disagree
100% it's truly beautiful immersive and
it makes me feel like I'm part of the
world and I want to live in it it's a
perfect night with dialog how are you
today I'm Mirabelle Monet
I run the fo'c'sle a boarding house for
sailors sorry
I reserved my beds for seamen here's an
example of some classic beautiful NPC
dialogue that you can listen in to and
really feel like you're part of a new
universe it's you hi what's going on
with you I ran into some goblins in the
woods not long ago nasty little beasts
horrible things I hear that the High
Elves train them
I can't imagine bye goodbye
greetings Argonian hello what's going on
with you heard any news from the other
province hello there's all these like
parodies of the dialogue it's so [ __ ]
good well I better get going
see ya
[Music]
oh there's so many of these going mail
you know what I'll probably sets up
tomorrow
I think this is the perfect one to
summarize it hello
we haven't been properly introduced
before I'm Michael by the way you must
be Alice yeah nice to meet you Alice
EJ well let's do you want to go over to
the park bench yeah thank you
well we both got autism haven't we yes
well that's good to know
well I guess the truth is I'm similar to
you as it's very difficult for me to
talk people have not met before like
yourself I have to pay you compliments
like for example
think of an example of what a compliment
is it seems your eyes are as brown as
the tree trunks
oh man I'm not uh there's really only
one way to end this with a goddamn
beautiful adoring fan this beautiful
specimen would follow you anywhere in
the game yes oh great and mighty grand
champion is there something you need
again I can't carry your shed shine your
boots that shine your moose and even
give him a back rub and sometimes a
night at loss slippy slippy down there
if you know what I mean
[ __ ] this video result Jesus Christ
[Music]
[Applause]
they know you can upload YouTube videos
at this point it's the champion I can't
believe it's you standing here
let's true
[Music]
blimpy on everyone the perfect game if
you haven't played it yet I suggest you
go check it out right now leave a like
if you enjoy buy a fidget spender and I
will see your breath
I mean sisters in the next
[Music]
and my corner stay Robin